Does reverse osmosis water filtration remove all the minerals? Should I use a mineral supplement?
Or should I purchase the remineralizer apparatus that is an option with the unit?
I think there's more misinformation about minerals on the internet than probably anything.
So reverse osmosis, does that take the minerals out of the water?
Yeah, probably. Yeah, it's taking minerals out of the water. It's taking heavy metals out of the
water. It's taking chemicals out of the water that you don't want to have. Oh no, oh no, that's a bad
thing. Says somebody on the internet who doesn't know what they're talking about. You need to add
minerals to your diet if you're taking all the minerals out of the water. Then reverse osmosis
creates quote-unquote dead water because it doesn't have any minerals left in it. And you're
going to die and you're going to have bone issues and your bones are going to fall apart because
you don't have any minerals. It's all misinformation. So number one, yes, reverse osmosis does take
minerals out of the water, but that's not a bad thing. So why would it be a bad thing? Don't we need
minerals? Yes, but the minerals that you're getting in the water are earth-bound minerals. They're not
good minerals to absorb. You don't absorb them well, and even if the ones that you do absorb
well, you don't utilize well. They're not double bonded to an amino acid. They're not going to be
well utilized in your body. That effect, they could actually be problematic if you have too high
mineral content in your water. So if you have well water with a very high mineral content,
it can actually be problematic. It can negatively affect your gut. And if you do absorb those things,
it can cause issues with your bones. You can end up with calcification of your tendons
and end up with tendonitis issues and all sorts of problems. Why? Well, these are minerals. Don't we
need them? They're not the this is you don't you don't we're not created to get our minerals from our
water. We're not created to get minerals by eating dirt. We're created to get minerals from eating
plants and eating animals that eat plants. So that's how we get our minerals. We don't get our minerals
from our water. We don't get our minerals from eating dirt. So we get our minerals from eating plants
that ain't dirt. We get our minerals from eating animals that ain't plants that ain't dirt.
So, and then the mineralizers that come along with units like this are just bogus,
bogus, bogus, bogus because all they are is a mineral, is a, is a earth-bound mineral that is
then rematerializing the water in minerals that you don't want to have in the first place.
It's like taking bad mineral supplement product. So, a bad mineral supplement product will be a
supplement, a mineral supplement product that is an earth-bound mineral, meaning that it's like
the liquid minerals that are out there, that are, that are a poor quality mineral that are not
bonded with a double bond. So, if you're taking a whole food mineral, a whole food product,
let's say like a greens product. That's an organic greens product. Let's say you're taking
there's minerals in there, right? Because they're in the plant and you're eating the plant. If you go
down to your garden and you eat your vegetables, you're getting minerals because the plant took the minerals
out of the soil as a, as a earth-bound mineral and then changed it into a double bonded amino acid
mineral which we then consume and it works in our body. We can absorb it well and it can be
utilized by ourselves in all sorts of different functions in our body. If we're just eating dirt,
then we don't absorb it well and that which we do absorb can actually not function well in our
body. It can't necessarily be used by ourselves and can actually cause more problems like I stated.
So, again, there's more misinformation about minerals than than many other things on the internet
and there's more miseducation about minerals. So does reverse osmosis remove all the minerals?
Yes, but that is not a bad thing. Should I supplement with a mineral supplement because of that?
No. Should you supplement with a mineral supplement? Maybe because you don't eat any vegetables?
Yes. Or maybe because you eat extra minerals because you're sweating a lot working outside or
because you're doing the soda, sweating a lot, losing your minerals? Well, yeah, that may be yes.
Or, you know, should I supplement with extra magnesium because, you know,
magnesium is the most needed mineral? Yes, that may be you should. But it's not because you're doing
reverse osmosis. So, I hope that helps answer that question because there's a lot of people
have that misunderstanding that there's a lot of companies out there that are even selling
a filtration systems that it's just they're just told they're just wrong. So, sorry, but I feel strongly